Salut à tous c'est les Pêcheurs de Trésors
Aujourd'hui nous sommes de retour dans la ville de Sète
A côté d'un pont
Avec des bateaux coulés, toujours
En compagnie de Alex
Regardez on va tester la pêche à l'aimant sous ce pont qui est profond
Oui, sympa le paysage encore
J'espère qu'on ne va pas coincer les aimants dans les rochers
ça va le faire
Si cet endroit n'a pas déjà été sondé, il devrait être rempli, allez premier lancé
Prêts les enfants ?
Je l'avais repérée aussi cette petite mallette
C'est le lance fusées de détresse ?
C'est un kit du bateau peut-être
Je pense
C'est peut-être ça
J'essaie ?
ça va être dur
Ouais essaie avec la branche
Sinon je vais sur le bateau
Tu n'y arriveras pas
Attends il y a un truc dedans
Rouge et vert
Tu le vois ?
A ton avis elle est pleine ou vide ?
Ah il y a bien quelque chose à l'intérieur
ça pue...
C'est un machin pour la pêche ou bien ...
Ah oui bouchon de pêche
Bon et bien c'est cool déjà
Oui c'est déjà ça
Rentre dans le bateau Quentin
Ouais je vais regarder ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur
On se déplace, on va de l'autre côté ?
Nous avons été rejoint par José et son fils, que vous avez vus dans la première vidéo à Sète
Et cette fois-ci José a son aimant
Ouais je l'ai retrouvé dans ma voiture, je pensais l'avoir égaré
J'y tiens tellement
Je tremblais quand je l'ai retrouvé !
Bon allez
On va déjà remonter ces trucs là qu'on arrive à apercevoir
Puis on se décalera
Pour voir si on arrive à trouver autre chose
C'est quoi ça ? Une chaise ?
Je vais voir ce que c'est que ce truc là bas
Ouais c'est vrai ?
C'est un parasol ça ?
j'ai quelque chose regardez
c'est un bloque volant de voiture
J'avais le même sur la Twingo 1
Et voilà
le beau parasol
Oh pardon
J'ai eu une pile aussi
Bonne dépollution
Belle dépollution
Ah tu connais les phrases types ! Ahaha
ça tu sais ce que c'est ?
C'est les chaises des guetteurs
Et ouais
Ils passent et ils les jettent
Des fois c'est même les policiers qui les jettent
j'ai déjà vu la police passer et récupérer toutes les chaises
Oh c'est un demi carter de scooter
Oui un carter de scooter
C'est à moitié en aluminium ça
C'est un coquillage ou une sorte de limace ?
je ne sais pas
C'est un cocon dégueulasse
de poisson ?
je vais le relâcher
tu le veux ? Tu veux gouter ?
Non non ça ira
Qu'est-ce que ça pue
petite trouvaille
je pense que c'est un morceau de Samsung
Ah ouais !
C'est cool ce que vous faites
Oui ici il y a de quoi faire en plus
Vous pouvez même trouver des armes
Oui, qui sait ?
Moi j'habite sur un bateau et on entends souvent des tirs
Et tu ne sais pas ou ils les jettent après ? Non ?
Ah non, dans ce cas je reste enfermée dans le bateau avec les chiens
Oui il vaut mieux
J'ai attrapé ton aimant ou pas ?
je ne sais pas
Ce chien est étonnant
Oui tu m'as attrapé
On a quelque chose
Rasta, on parle de toi la petite star
On tir ?
Ah mais oui c'est clairement une star
Là j'ai encore quelque chose
Je ne fais pas un seul lancé vidé
Sous le pont c'est remplis
Mon aimant se décolle à chaque fois à moi
Oh un beau couteau
regarder ce couteau de pêche
Il est fermé là
Un peu de dégrippant et ça va le faire
Oui oui
C'est de l'inox
Franchement nickel
Parfait parfait
belle trouvaille
Super
C'est un couteau de qualité quand même
Ah un autre
j'en ai eu 2 d'un coup
Il y en a un autre, un tout petit
regarde Bapt
Baptiste j'en ai un autre
ils étaient ensemble
Deux couteaux en un seul lancé c'est stylé
C'est pour chasser les coquillages
franchement bien
L'autre en face est en train de me casser le cerveau
Oui il est relou
C'est du plastique ça
Alors c'est quoi ça encore ?
Un extincteur
Un extincteur de bateau
Attention il va peut-être exploser
Ah ben oui il a explosé
Tu le disais en rigolant ?
Oui
Il a dû passer un sacré bout de temps dans l'eau
Il disait en rigolant de faire attention
Ouais c'est bien un extincteur
Et il a explosé
T'es fou
Oui il doit être là depuis très longtemps
Bizarrement l'intérieur était encore sec
C'est moi qui fais les trucs dangereux d'habitude
heureusement qu'il n'y avait plus de gaz
Ouais !
C'est pas un vélo, c'est les trucs pour rebondir, avec un ressort
Ah oui trop bien !
Test le
Je m'en fou, il faut le tester
T'es malade
Si si tu le testes
C'est fait pour sauter
Je vais me tuer avec ça
Mais oui essaie le sur le rocher là
C'est un parapluie !
Il est où Rasta ?
Il est couché
Il va juste dans les boulangeries
Une cuillère
Là j'ai deux choses
C'est un plot
Un plot de signalisation
On est abonné à ça, comme la dernière fois
En ce moment, j'en fait tout le temps
Elle est pas mal ta barre
Qu'est-ce que tu nous fait Alex ?
Ouais, c'est un chariot
Il y a encore quelque chose
Allé, un pneu
Pneu de vélo
Il n'y a rien loin, ils ont tout jeté juste en dessous
Oh, une casserole
Une casserole et une demi trottinette
On dirait une barrière, ou deux barrière
C'est bizarre
Il y a tout qui se soulève
Regarde, il y a une trottinette
C'est un gros tas énorme
Je vais essayer de lever avec toi
Ah toi aussi, tu as un truc avec qui s'approche
On essaie de leur amener
Il y a du câble ouais
Ah ! Il vient
On dirait encore une trottinette
Bien joué
Première trottinette de José
Franchement, je suis fier
Eh ben ! Il y a beaucoup ici
Ah oui !
Les gars ! Troisième couteau
Il y a une fourchette aussi
C'est un petit couteau un peu nul mais bon
Ca reste sympa
Ah mais c'est un poisson, attend on va le relâcher
Ah oui, Rasta a trouvé un poisson
Vas-y Alex, tu devrais pouvoir le coincer
Parfait
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Une boule de pétanque ?
Si on trouve les trois, on fait une partie
Qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
C'est une boule de plage
On le voit au poids
Une boule de plage, dommage
Regardez les gars
Une clef de Mercedes
Clef de Mercedes c'est pas mal, j'ai deux nouveau couteaux
Je fais ma collection de couteaux
Il est sympa celui là
Surement un couteau de dealer
Surement balancé dans l'eau avant de se faire fouiller
Dès que la police arrive, ils jettent tout
Alex, il faut que tu essaies les clefs sur le parking
Tu essaies toutes les Mercedes sur le parking
On dirait une fausse
Elle est bizarre
C'est une lampe
C'est une lampe en fait
Belle trouvaille quand même
Une corde
Bizarre ça
Avec un amortisseur
Ouais on dirait, la corde est attaché avec, dans la chambre à air
Il y a du poids là, il y a des trucs
Encore une trottinette
J'ai mi le pied sur la trottinette, elle c'est cassée en deux
Un cadre de scooter carrément les gars
Ca ne rigole plus là
Une fusillade juste là
On dirait un bijoux oriental, je ne sais pas
Si vous savez en commentaire ce que c'est
Un échiquier électronique, sympa
Si vous voulez jouer après la pêche à l'aimant
Vu ce qu'il reste
Qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre ?
Pas de couteau hélas
Petite pause repas
On nourri les canards au lieu de pêcher
Bon, on c'est décalé
On va voir un peu ce qu'on a ici
Une casserole, beurk
Elle est trop trouée pour faire des châtaignes
En pêche à l'aimant, il y a le mot pêche, il nous faut jamais l'oublier
T'arrives à reconnaitre ? - Non
Remet le à l'eau
Voilà
Alors, c'est quoi ?
Il est hyper lourd
Quand il fait ça, je filme parce que une fois sur deux, il tombe
Attend, il y a le panneau avec
C'est bloqué oui
Oh non !
On a perdu un morceau
Attend, je le repousse
Voilà !
Il est super lourd !
C'est original !
C'est dommage il n'y a plus le panneau. - Oui il est tombé
Avec un peu de chance on peut le choper
Là, une plaque de scooter
Regardes comme est abimée
Ouais
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Bizarre
Elle a été collée avec du silicone ?
Oui elle a été recollée
34 Département de l'Hérault
Je vais faire comme dans les Western pour chercher ma boule
Un, deux, trois
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'il y avait sur ce panneau
Propriété privée, accès réglementé
Tout simplement
Tu as bien repéré quelque chose
Ton aimant permet de repérer les objets
Mais après il n'est pas assez puissant
Ca n'accroche pas bien ?
Tu as un bout
C'est un bout de dérailleur de vélo
Ah ! Bah c'est un vélo
On sent qu'il se lève mais n'accroche pas plus que ça
Tu vois derrière le rocher, il y a du blanc
Il arrive, il arrive !
C'est sûr, c'est un vélo
C'est un beau vélo je crois
Pour une fois
Il faudrait le grappin
Mais le grappin est dans la voiture
On le voit bien
Encore un peu
Il est bloqué dans les rochers
Il vient ! Il vient !
Il vient, il vient, ne bouges pas
Il n'y a pas les roues
Ca devait être des rouges en bâton
Ca coute une fortune, le mec a volé les roues
Bianchi Countervail
Il est vraiment beau
Composite technologie
Il vient de saint Etienne les gars
C'est beau, beau vélo
Je pense que celui-là, il faut garder le cadre
Belles pédales et regardes l'avant
Eduardo Bianchi
Il est super léger
C'est notre plus beau vélo
C'est du carbonne
Pour ça qu'on arrivait pas à l'accrocher
On l'a accroché uniquement sur le pédalier
Il est neuf !
On l'a sorti alors qu'il n'est même pas magnétique
Magnifique
Le vélo il vaut 1000 euros
Entier oui, largement, plus même
On va essayer de ne pas l'abimer
Ton carbone il est piqué
C'est que la peinture ça
Vous avez vu, il y a des rétroviseurs là
A l'aide du numéro de série du vélo, nous avons réussi à retrouver le propriétaire
Nous lui avons donné rendez-vous pour lui restituer
Il est abimé mais vous pouvez peut être récupérer les pédales ou la selle
Le cadre, ça va être compliqué
Je vais vous le laisser
Ah, carrément ?
Il n'y a rien à récupérer ici
Je pensais que les pédales c'était possible
Ouais mais bon ...
On ne l'a pas touché, on ne savait pas si vous vouliez le faire réparer
Je peux le prendre en photo ?
Oui
Comment c'est passé le vol ?
On me l'a carrément volé dans mon garage
Je suis allé porter plainte, ils m'ont dit que ce n'était pas la peine de le chercher donc je n'attendais plus
C'était il y a longtemps ?
Il y a 3 ans à peu prêt
L'assurance m'a remboursée
De toute façon, même pour l'assurance il est déclaré inutilisable
Vous l'avez trouvé où ?
A Sete
Je vous montre l'endroit exact
En face du Lidl
Du grand Lidl de Sete
Oui, oui
Il y a une route qui passe au dessus du canal
Il était là, sous le pont
J'habite juste avant
J'habite juste à côté, à 300 mètres
Je pense qu'ils ont volés que les roues
On nous a dit que c'était très difficile à revendre pour les voleurs à cause du numéro de série
C'est débile, ils l'ont massacré juste pour voler les roues
C'est dommage, c'était un beau vélo
Vous pouvez essayer de le nettoyer mais il est resté longtemps dans l'eau
Ouais, je ne sais pas trop
Comment vous avez fait pour me contacter ?
Il y avait son autocollant là
On l'a appelé et il nous a donné votre numéro
En général, quand on trouve des motos par exemple l'assurance a déjà remboursée
Dans ce cas là ça ne change rien
Après comme on a compris que c'était un beau vélo, on s'est dit qu'il y avait certainement des parties à récupérer comme les pédales...
Mais du coup, comment vous l'avez trouvé ?
Nous on fait des vidéos sur internet
Et on filme les sessions durant lesquelles on récupères tout ces qui est magnétique et immergé dans les canaux
Ah dans les canaux, je pensais que vous faisiez ça en mer
Non non, c'est dans les canaux principalement
Et on a des aimants très puissants, je vais vous montrer
Comme celui-là
C'est un petit modèle, les autres sont en cours d'utilisation là
mais pour vous donner une idée avec le vélo qui est principalement en carbonne
Il y a certaines parties aimantées comme les vis
Rien que ça ça permet de le soulever et de le tirer
Et on trouve de tout, vélos, motos, et on filme nos découvertes
Et on emmène tout, c'est aussi une façon de nettoyer les cours d'eau
Mais effectivement la plupart du temps c'est des déchets
Essayez de le nettoyer vous pouvez peut-être le revendre
Ouais, bon le revendre je pense pas, comme il a le numéro de série déclaré volé et vu son état
Mais bon
On a quand même les preuves vidéos comme quoi il a été volé ailleurs
Merci beaucoup c'est très gentil
je vois dois quelque chose ?
Non rien du tout, désolé de vous avoir fait venir pour ne pas le prendre
Vraiment nous n'acceptons rien
Non, je vous le dis des fois on rend même des bijoux
On refuse tout le temps, notre récompense c'est de faire une belle vidéo
Donc vraiment pas besoin
Je me rappellerai de vous et je ferais votre pub
Vous regarderez nos vidéos
C'est Pêcheurs de Trésors
On est sur Youtube Facebook etc
On veut juste faire de belles vidéos
Ce qui nous intéresses c'est de trouver les gens et de comprendre comment ils ont perdus certains objets
Parfois c'est plus sentimental que pour le prix
C'est vrai que je pourrais essayer de le nettoyer mais bon...
Oui c'est peut-être du boulot pour pas grand chose
J'ai repris le même vélo
Ok, bon ben ça va
On va voir ce qu'on en fait, écoutez avec plaisir
Je ne vous dis pas à une prochaine fois du coup
Ouais je n'espère pas
Merci beaucoup
Avec plaisir bonne journée
Notre cousin travaille dans la location et la réparation de vélos
Nous allons lui transmettre et on verra ce qu'il réussit à faire
Ecoutez c'est la fin de cette super vidéo, merci ceux qui ont participé et regardé !
Magnifiques découvertes, merci Alex, merci José et Rosé
Super vélo
Pour un débutant je suis fier de moi
C'est José qui l'a repéré c'est vrai
Avec mon aimant je n'arrivais pas à l'accrocher
Il faut donc un bon aimant
Son aimant n'est pas top pour le fer, mais pour le carbone c'est efficace !
Il marche super même si le carbone n'est pas magnétique
Voilà, ce n'est pas aimanté mais on peut en trouver
Je leur laisse le vélo
C'est gentil
j'ai quand même perdu ma boule de pétanque
Mais j'ai trouvé un vélo à la place
Mais boule de pétanque perdue veut dire partie 3 de prévue à Sète
ouais super
On reviendra, ici il y a plein de choses
On va faire une bonne action pour notre abonné José qui collectionne les couteaux
On va lui offrir le moins joli
Super sympa ça
Il m'a dit de choisir
Il collectionne les couteaux, on lui offre donc le bouchon de pêche ahaha
Tu sais quand tu es collectionneur de couteaux tu les trouves tous beaux
On voit les larmes de Quentin qui coulent
Il prend le plus beau
Voila, mais ils sont tous beaux
Moi je dis que c'est lui le plus beau Quentin
Non je ne vais pas en prendre deux quand même
regarde celui là il ne te plaît pas ?
Il est bien lui pour le fromage
C'est pour mon fils
C'est un griffoir
Ils me l'ont offert et moi je vais le donner à mon fils de 13 ans qui va être très content
C'est déjà un grand collectionneur
Merci les gars, ça lui fera un beau souvenir
Avec plaisir
Il doit rester des couteaux sous le pont d'ailleurs
Je vais y aller cette nuit et pêcher pendant que vous ne serrez pas là, tranquille
Je ne partagerai pas
belle pêche
Ah merde
T'inquiètes pas
ça sera en vidéo